volga plage sur une surface de 30
hectares habitations spontanée et
maisons de fortune se côtoient depuis
plus d'un demi siècle rue du sentier au
coeur du quartier une sexagénaire vit
avec sa famille sous 1 3 qui fuit ici
l'humilité est insoutenable
on allait mais cet ascendant et on a le
mal de vivre
campa dans les habitations ne peut il
nous faut chercher des trucs à mettre
des torchons tout ça des serpillières du
moins tout ça alors et j'ai mon fils
haussier sauvant grippe et à cause de
cela les cris de détresse de cette
habitante ont-ils été entendu ce matin
le maire et le préfet lui ont rendu
visite à leur sortie
l'heure était aux promesses ça nous
montre vraiment l'utilité de l'opération
qu'on est en train de mettre en place
c'est à dire avoir une réponse qu'ils
soient concrètes qui se veut rapide
là ça permet de concilier les
contraintes administratives et puis
d'aller d'aller très vite dans les
travaux le principe c'est que on met en
place un chantier d'insertion sont les
jeunes même du chantier d'insertion des
jeunes du quartier qui viendront faire
les travaux de rénovation
les jeunes dont parle le représentant de
l'état sont une quinzaine ils ont été
présentés en milieu de matinée à des
partenaires économiques et
institutionnels
ils participeront un chantier
d'insertion sur une période de 24 mois
les projets à réaliser vont de
l'aménagement des entrées de quartier à
une trentaine d'habitations indigne à
réhabiliter il y aurait même un projet
de jardin partagé
le maire de la capitale voit à travers
cette initiative de multiples intérêts
ça permet d'apporter une amélioration du
cadre de vie
ça permet également d'impliquer et pour
moi c'est ce qui est le plus important
d'impliquer les jeunes des pics et les
acteurs du quartier pour qu'ils
continuent à développer leur quartier ça
lui permet aux grands développements du
coach et fonctionnel nous ne sommes
prêts à
comment je vais dire aller jusqu'au bout
investir notre temps et notre énergie
pour donner à la volga quelque chose de
vraiment beau des jeunes en ordre de
marche des projets en devenir ces
initiatives auraient émergé suite à des
réunions de quartier là où le quartier
manque un passé qu'il crée une agence de
développement local en partenariat avec
la mairie l'état les collectivités la
cacem les administrations et en salle à
on a réussi quelque chose aujourd'hui
des institutions comme la dé l agence
des 50 pas et des foules à sarah son
partenaire des projets initiés à volga
ce quartier d'autoconstruction dans
lequel les nouvelles générations
insuffle une nouvelle énergie affichera
bientôt grâce à ses habitants un nouveau
visage